I was on a podcast recently with with an
entrepreneur named Petros he owns a gym
gym 700 different franchises of gyms
that he owns absolute start of a guy and
he said he's one of these guys that
actually knows how business works and
he's good at what he's doing very often
and very open about his mistakes flaws
all these things he's doing he asked me
a question he says what do you think
about the market crash I said I can't
wait for it he says what do you mean I
said I honestly can't wait for it why do
you say you can't wait for it that's
it's gonna hurt a lot of people what do
mean can't wait for the market crash I
said first of all it's inevitable and
everytime market crash happens wealth is
made by those who are prepared for it
what do you mean go a little deeper
listen Mickey Mantle's baseball card PSA
10 1952 was just bought for twelve
million dollars I think that guy that
bought it for twelve million dollars if
a major market crash happens here's a
need for cash not a lot of people have
cash and say I'm sitting on sixty
million dollars of cash and I go up to
my cell give me three million dollars I
will take you for three man that paid
for twelve million dollars I'm giving
you cash right now you don't have to
worry about it okay do 4.2 million okay
four million I'll give it you
four million twelve million I wait five
years ten years Markie comes back up I
sell that twelve twelve million dollar
Mickey Mantle call for twenty four
million dollars I spent four million
dollars to twenty four million dollars
that's 6x my money because I had cash
right when the market crashes homes are
on sale like right now I'm in Plano I'm
in Dallas everybody thinks oh my gosh
housing in Texas is so cheap everybody
wants to say that 20 years ago was today
it's the same price as LA I'm telling
you right now hole pricing in Texas is
the same as in LA if you're living in
Plano Highland Park those types of
communities you're looking they just
sold the house in Dallas for like 30 40
50 million dollars Dallas Texas the most
expensive house the biggest house in
America was just on sell in Dallas on
our seventy-five million dollars what
are these things
it's little overpriced right so you got
to be sitting on cash because some of
the guys that spent twelve million
dollars on the house and he put us all
his money into it the market crashes he
done said have the cash he has to sell
that house for four point two million
three point eight million dollars and
the person who can capitalize on that
opportunity is the one that has cash by
the way some people say Pat that's cold
that's cruel that's not fair isn't that
why capitalism so ugly
no it's greed
for the person that wasn't prepared for
market crash that person deserves
everything they get it's greed the fact
that the person thought the market is
always going to go up 9 years straight
we've been in the positive how are you
not prepared for it you became too
irrational too confident too optimistic
the loss paranoia your stomach got too
big so you start kind of paying
attention to everything the reason why
I'm making this video is for you to be
aware that when this happens you need
cash and my recommendation is 15 to 25
percent cash not a lot of people agree
with that number I agree with that
number it's work for me here's what I
mean by it
you got a million dollars right now in
mutual funds stocks bonds real estate
just make sure you got somewhere between
150 to a quarter million dollars in cash
today